all right yo boo lakehead podcast
we've got the writer of writers yeah
your writer is here ladies and gentlemen
kev
thanks for having me back what up good
man welcome welcome what's your first
time on the bootleg
podcast yeah we had you like real ninety
two three before
yeah shout outs to dj hey you know shout
out to dj head the kova to shut down the
radio station
yeah it's quiet so we're here at my
studio um well how you been man i've
been good man just working
so give us like a rundown on everything
you got going on right now
um i'm dropping the album october 30th
i would call it an ep because my album
coming after like a few of those
but i'm dropping on october 30th this
friday
it's called i really wrap two shout outs
to uh 38 spec
shout outs to royster59 shout outs to
davey shouts to fred money and shout
outs to all the producers on there that
produce
fire top to bottom you know i don't play
man you and
i take this seriously you got royce on
there yeah me and royce it's serious
i didn't want to leak it i just want
people to hear it when it drops when the
project drops
um now obviously most people
know you from your dip set ties i want
to kind of go back before that kind of
give me your history
of how you got into music man like we're
like like
at what year did you start taking this
[ __ ] serious obviously there was
there there was a jail writer before you
started working with dipset yeah hell
yeah i was 11 when i first started
um i was influenced by like wu tang
snoop dogg
um tupac big big pun big al right you
know what i mean
but yeah i started rapping as a at 11
12 13 you know running the streets
battling
getting my making a name for myself and
then somebody at 16 somebody
introduced me to killer and hauling one
day so yeah
and then history from there so from 16
on you was just
cam locked in with you from 16 and all
yeah it's a fact
damn showing me the ropes you know i was
just like i was like a sponge around
jewels around cam around gym
just you know picking up little things
from everything
business at what point in time so
obviously 16 years old you meet cam
how long how long after that was it
before you actually
you know were officially well it took me
a minute because
i had to prove myself you know and we
was like we from harlem so we always
competitive
so cam used to touch me like i was wild
young and
it don't matter where it was at i'll
take the train there i'll walk there it
didn't matter i was that hungry so
you know he'll make sure i was on my
toes so
anytime i come around he'll be like yo
let me hear something
it could be a room full of people just
we could be at a bar right here's
something
and if it sounds like something i spit
already nah i heard that let me hear
something else
are you falling off oh i know you ain't
slacking
right so i never i never wanted that
reaction from anybody so i always stayed
on my toes and
i always proved myself like they didn't
have to come to me
like i hear is a video shoot i pull up
to the video shoot with my mixtape done
yo cam look i'm done here i'm ready i'm
ready to go i just need you to host it
i'ma put it out
what year what year was uh okay i don't
know how old you are but when you're 16
are you first 35
so when you when you're 16 you first
meet cam
this is around what the which era
is this this is after ste this is after
yeah this is around the time
i met him uh right when juelz got signed
jim didn't even have a deal yet so is
this around take me home
no come home come home take me home i'm
tripping that's like a drake song
yeah bro i just had this this huge drake
argument
all day today on the internet and i was
just listening to drake's album in my
car
he's all right that's what the argument
was about um
but no come home with me um i feel like
was like cam's like coming out party
uh you know his first project with
rockefeller
and i feel like that kicked off the real
like obviously dipset was doing their
thing with the mixtapes and i feel like
that really kicked off the wave of like
the movement where if it was felt
nationwide like
oh yeah like dipset was something that
wasn't just like
new york secret you know what i'm saying
no that's a fact i don't know if cam
planned it or i really think it probably
happened naturally but he has that
confidence like all of us from harlem
has that confidence
where it's like this is this what we
gonna do b we gonna put out this we gon
we was like the first dip set honestly
was like the first
rap group to put out street mixtapes
without dj's like a dj
because usually you could debate jesus
you could debate g
unit you could debate because they we
came out yeah but they still had like
when you say without a dj like obviously
they had who kid and
i think who kid was was a dj was hosting
their team
no but k sleigh helped hosted i was i
was gonna say casey hosted the dip said
[ __ ]
yeah um so were you were around
during you might not have been official
yet but you were around like
the diplomatic immunity wave like yeah i
was supposed to be on the first
album but the song me and kim and ma
heard mcgruff from harlem
shouts to him we had didn't get cleared
so little things like that i felt like
god put
in my in my path in my way for me to go
harder from haters to little
little obstacles like that to where it's
like not
easy for me so i can always stay on my
toes and always focus
but she was around during that time no i
was around i was just crazy that's like
yo tell me about those times man cause i
just remember vividly
as a kid buying the double xl
where everybody was in there with the
teams and that was like when i first saw
like
i really got to kind of like figure out
who jim jones was
yeah it is like i ever i forget
everybody had jerseys on and then x
double x throwback jerseys yeah mitchell
teams and [ __ ] like i remember that [ __ ]
vividly like the airbrush tim you know
yeah yep yep but
like what was it like being around that
energy because we look at it now and
it's like
we miss that in hip-hop you know i think
um
dipset is so nostalgic to so many people
um to me you know specifically i
remember you know just like that whole
era just just just the feeling that it
brought to the game and like
i feel like it's missing but you were
there for it like did you realize like
how special this [ __ ] was at the time
because at the time it wasn't like
dipset was like the
commercially the biggest [ __ ] but it was
like in this it was like
culturally so big you know what i'm
saying like
obviously cam had hit records jewels had
hit records but i mean like
like culturally they meant so much at
that time
you did you know like what you were part
of at that time when you were like a kid
the reason i even got down with kid
and holland as somebody to get me to him
is because
he him and jim and and juelz already had
that wave already where
it was just a hood wave where it's like
everybody knew
i mean i'm pretty sure other places knew
about juelz in the beginning or whatever
off cam sde album
but um but uh like uh uh
the mixtapes and and and those
albums or whatever had them as her
legends already
so me just i mean getting down with them
at that time was like
a dream come true it's like yo that's
like somebody being from brooklyn
getting signed with jay-z or somebody
being from l.a and getting down with
snoop dogg dog pound
right right right what i'm saying but it
was just it was magical it's like you
know what i mean cause it's like
i would come in and you know
they swag is just like well i was swag
cause i was there but i'm just saying
i'm looking from the outside looking in
you know what i'm saying but um
it was just it was dope it was dope you
know what i'm saying just from the
fashion to the
from to the touring to the radio
freestyles
uh uh everything from when we was at the
bottom to where we at the top
everything the whole the whole uh uh
run we had was was just epic it was dope
do you remember how you were when you
officially finally got
got got your name on the on the contract
with cam
i was 18 years old i remember because uh
we was on a tour bus and i was waiting
for the because we was on a tour for uh
diplomatic immunity too yeah and i
wanted to uh
oh matter of fact cam wanted me cam like
yo i wanted the toy to be over matter of
fact
i'm like damn i want to get back and
pick up my chat cause i had just signed
or whatever
and cam like nah b you ain't picking up
the check
until y'all drink a whole box of
scissors we celebrate
when you added the drink it was like 100
nips
i remember that i remember his drink
yeah it was just like dumb hot but i
ain't gonna hold you i was happy
you know what i'm saying and i didn't
care i'm like i'm gonna drink at least
half a box and tell them i'm sick
but um yeah you know that was that was
that was dope you know i'm saying soon
as we got back
i signed i remember that was my last
time i took the train
and somebody took my ear off to death
like yeah what you doing on the train
don't worry it should be the last time
yo how i never
got the trices or how was it good yeah
and i was good
it was good i mean it's just different
it was this is just what was it because
i just remember seeing the ads
like the source and [ __ ] like i wasn't
old enough to [ __ ] drink obviously it
was it had to flavor like a uh
like a um not 90 knots like uh
hypnotic hypnotic purple yeah like a
purple hypnotic you know what i mean
type of chase i miss that whole wave in
life i've never even drank hypnotic and
i'd like to consider myself a mild
alcoholic now but that
but that's how you hear pretend uh you
drinking incredible hawks
but anyway oh okay okay okay
but look um miss that whole wave in life
that's how you know
the the the just the aura our aura how
crazy it was because
jim had that idea and
you know when the artist says yo i'm
gonna come out with my own liquor and
all that it doesn't matter where he at
his in his career
it's dope it's salutable but we care
about your music more than
the side things that you're coming out
with but every when we came out with
that
everyone ran with it that bottle was
like a rose bottle in the hood
everywhere we went it was just it was
just fire i mean just to
you know we was that influential i mean
when i toured the world that's when i
really realized how big dipset was
going to japan switzerland sweden you
know all those places i can only imagine
on my own at that
yeah that's crazy um fast forward
a year and a half or two ago when did
when did you when did you guys drop your
your project upstage how long ago was
that
it was like last year or the year 2018.
so yeah so about two years ago
was you guys dropped it the same day as
dip said dropped their [ __ ]
the same day as diplomatic community and
then i remember
hitting play on it and i was on the
intro
yeah you guys used like a question i
asked jim in an interview like as the
intro and i was like oh
and that's what i think when i was five
yeah hey fam yeah yeah you said thanks
for the shout out that's why i'm like
you know what let me hit him nah but uh
i think that there's like what's your
relationship like with
everybody in the crew now because i feel
like that kind of felt
like there might be some some you know
obviously you guys dropped no
the record no reunions like is there any
static it's just a bunch of us and we're
not always on the same page you know
what i'm saying so
you know it's all love it's not it
wasn't like on some i i'm gonna put out
the album and it's as a diss you know
what i'm saying oh as a response it's
like okay i hear that they put not an
album
let's do our own version since we can't
do uh i ain't get no phone call
but i'm not gonna lie a week before i
was releasing
jewels had called me you know what i'm
saying to get on the album but
this is before he was locked up by it
right oh yeah of course oh yeah
yeah shout outs to jewels he just came
home yeah he did shout out to him but um
it wasn't yeah it wasn't no static but
as far as now
um yeah i got no problems with no i
spoke to i spoke to jim i speak to
jewels
you know me here and it seems like cam
is the one who
consistently cam is the one that messed
everything up nah i [ __ ] with you
no but it just seems like he it feels
like he's the guy who's like
i feel like jim and juelz are always
cool i feel like it's always like
a cam thing at least from the outside
looking in as a fan like
yeah i mean you know cam is cam as cam
you know what i'm saying he's he's gonna
move on his own time so
it is what it is do you know how he felt
about you guys doing that
about doing the project yeah i don't
know i heard from
from somebody that he probably mad at me
but you know so have you talked about
the killer um no i haven't no i haven't
but shout outs to kim you know what i'm
saying he's doing business with my guy
ryan
we got a whole cbd uh company coming out
or whatever
uh called legends that have where we're
doing you know lines with different
legends or whatever you know check out
that it's coming soon
do you find it um
a gift and a curse being a social like
obviously
with being a part of dip said and the
lore in the history there's always
uh a built-in fan base for that like
it's almost like
you know fan base buys like as soon as
like
you like somebody finds out your dip set
like right now with tde
so if tde signs somebody they got crazy
fans that are just going to [ __ ] with
that artist no matter what
is that a gift and a curse to kind of
like always carry the dip set like which
you like
like is it it's a gift and a curse
because it's like
sometimes a person might not know how to
answer a certain question
at a certain moment you know what i'm
saying because it's a bunch of us you
know what i'm saying plus
that name is attached so anywhere i go
whether i do an interview next week
them questions is gonna come up you know
what i'm saying so but i don't think
it's a
it's a curse at all you know what i mean
i don't think it's a curse um
because i helped build that you know
what i'm saying so i don't think it's a
curse yeah we talk about harlem and
harlem's got such a crazy history i
remember the first time i ever went to
new york
the first like one of the only things
that i cared to do was go to harlem and
take a picture in front of the
big al mural oh yeah we was just out
there i had the ferrari out there
shooting my yeah before me and my
baby mama at the time i we took the
train and i was like look i just need to
get this one picture that's dope you
know what i'm saying
that's crazy we went and ate at uh
what's the soul food spot there
the big popular soul food place oh you
told my roof chris you're talking about
uh
soul food spot oh i'm not rude chris amy
roots my bad
yeah sylvias i went to sylvia's yeah
yeah
fred is more outside than me i'm in the
studio all day he said i mean
yeah fred that's him that's i'm outside
yo jay you got to come outside
yeah so like you've obviously been
putting in work but like with with
with the new project davey's somebody
also who you know is is one of the great
side of the
out of the city right now right shout
outs to davies
is it like you you mentioned that
there's going to be an album how do you
separate what's on the ep what's on the
album like do you tuck certain [ __ ] like
this is the album [ __ ]
so yeah because i with albums
we had i got songs that are like they
sound like album cuts
with my eps or my mixtapes or my street
albums or whatever you want to label
them as long as they not
it's not called the album it's more of a
like uh
i'm i'm proving myself i still got it
i'm still better than everybody
this is how i'm coming so you know what
time it is when this album is dropping
see the album
you'll have some of that but you'll have
more of a mixture of concepts and
real songs laid out with hooks and i
mean a few skits
this is to get warmed up again i haven't
put nothing out in two years so
that's crazy to think how how big of a
wrench was you you going to jail man do
you think in your momentum because i
felt like you had so much momentum
it was a good that's a gift and a curse
honestly because the curse is taking me
away from my family taking my freedom
away obviously
and taking my career away for the moment
what about the gift part
the gift is uh snapping me out of it and
keeping me focused and waking me up it
just made me aware it got me back into
books and
really has me more focused like how long
was your bid
two years i mean yeah that's that's a
lifetime in hip-hop
yeah that's that's yeah i mean if i
wasn't
i mean you look around all the top top
rappers are what
how old did they my age yeah dude
i just had this conversation with benny
like then he's old like not all damn
nah then he's like an older like you
know we look like
generic hip-hop fans look at griselda as
these new artists because he came out
like well oh four
these guys have been grinding for a
minute like these guys are my age like
yo like these guys aren't new rappers
they you're just hearing them now but
these are grown ass men
you know what i wanted to ask benny i
wanted to see because i back in the day
i always heard the name black sopranos
so i wanted to know if they always if he
always went with that with that name
i think that that's been around for a
while yeah okay yeah there's and then
even griselda
didn't become griselda officially until
i think like 2016
it was uh i forget what westside gun had
what the name of his label was prior to
that
but yeah the buffalo [ __ ] yeah they got
it on smash
how inspiring is that to see like bars
the [ __ ] it's five it gets moving
it gets me it gets me like jealous
but not in a bad way right right right
and it gets me motivated but that's what
that's what the two the 2000s used to do
for me
like the fabs jaded kiss albums
lloyd banks freestyles like all of those
freestyles and
dudes that was really lyrical from stack
bundles to everybody that was
that was really rapping yeah it's like
they they kept me on my toes for one for
two
they motivated me when it's like it's
like i'm i'm hating
and i'm motivated at the same time it's
like oh he killed that
i gotta go crazy the next time i go up
there i gotta
go crazy on the next freestyle i do you
know what i'm saying
because uh now though i mean well before
griselda
and after the 2000s obviously it just
was
dropped man it's like yeah you know if
you were paying attention there it
wasn't
like if you were like a super you know
underground head but like definitely on
the on the forefront yeah
the [ __ ] is i always say like the dark
gears are like
2017 through 2019 when the soundcloud
[ __ ] really took over
it was bad man there was like even when
i came on a little pump
the little pump era yeah that that error
that [ __ ] was
i mean it's still going on nah i think
that shit's finally dying out man i
really do like i think all that antics
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] like perfect it's
fading out the six nine [ __ ]
everybody it was like a [ __ ] car
crash nobody could look away
but then when the music came out no one
cared like yeah
i think it was more about let's see
what's gonna happen the antics
yeah like all you know his story is
insane
like whenever they make his movie like
i'ma watch it because it's a crazy story
like if someone just told you that
and like without knowing who he was or
having any sort of personal feelings to
it you'd be like
nah that's crazy fam come on like
look like that's a movie you'd watch
because like this [ __ ] is it's a crazy
story but yeah
i think that that whole wave of like
people being known more for the [ __ ]
they pop on the cloud
than their music i think low-key kind of
helped too because people aren't
standing on couches and clubs right now
they're like that's a fact they're
consuming music in their headphones you
got to ride in their cars
yeah you got a wrap and that's i think
it's it's helping
bring a lot of the dope [ __ ] to the to
the left yeah that's a fact 100
because if you look the week that benny
the butcher his black daughter
yeah freddie gibbs is thriving gibbs
conway
tons of dope [ __ ] is thrilling i got 38
special
yeah 38 smash is crazy and he's been
nice
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure he's crazy
i need to get him up here
yeah yeah him and benny's project was
crazy a couple years ago
but yeah i think like uh you know with
you i think it's like
it's it's like you said like it was a
gift and a curse that you you know went
away and
so how different was the like
the dynamic of the crew from when you
went into when you got out
when i went in it was already it was
still like fractured
yeah it was it was like everybody doing
their own thing i mean it was like that
before
but we moved as a unit i think fame and
money
it just made like our circle crowded
because now once we all pop
now we all got our entourages and now
it's not just us
it's all of us it's like this entourage
that entourage that entourage so
i don't know i just think maybe it
complicated things but it's all love
it's not like
i think if kim wants to pick up the
phone and call anybody
he could make a dips reunion happen
anytime no for sure
yeah no i think he's got that back yo we
were just
talking about how back in the day
dipset it was like a thing like a
signature to rhyme the same words
to rhyme the same words yeah i think in
my heart i think jewels started that no
for sure that's a jewel steak oh
i just was listening to some throwback
freaks that he had and that was the
first because i studied lyrics for real
and that's the first time i seen that
scheme
where he because cam wasn't doing that
on like sde and even come home
cam started doing that after jewels but
it didn't really matter because joel's
is his artist you know what i'm saying
so
but yeah jewels i think jewel started
that when he said
you think a good job is making 25 an
hour
got cats selling 25 20s by the hour
yeah that's what he said and i'm the one
paying them 25 an hour
yeah nah 25 for a rock craze when
you think of it like if someone told you
like yo
they go ride the same [ __ ] but it's it's
it means something different every time
every time it's like it makes it that
much harder yeah
facts facts it's almost harder to do
that than rhyming with a new word that's
easy
yeah yeah you know what i was just
telling i had my video shoot
uh for this song nothing means nothing
off my album of my
ep coming out october 30th friday
yeah friday featuring thirty-eight
that's just coming out monday
so this will be out already dope so the
ep's out
yeah ep is out go get that and
if you're watching this then you already
know the ep crazy and if you don't then
go listen to that but anyway
i was just shooting a video in the
heights with my god 38 special and i was
telling them
because on the verse that he spit he
rhymed for like 32 bars but the same
rhyme like the same how you explaining
like the same ramen pattern like he
never switched the rhyme
scheme huh just you know the scheme like
the
yeah like he's never yeah like that he
just
rhymed with not the same words no but
the same scheme
yeah the same scheme like it's never
switched out to ron with anything else
and it was fire straight through
i'm like that's fire that's impressive
to keep that going
because it's so easy to just say two
lines and then switch it again and then
and then a lot of these rappers they
don't rhyme multiple syllables
so to me this don't be sounding
impressive but i know to the people it's
like
nah that was some real shitty kick
though yeah i think everybody has their
own thing i think uh
you know there's artists who say things
in an extremely simple way but the way
they say it is
their character what they stand for you
know the way they say it
you know i think that there's guys who
rap really [ __ ] fast that don't say
anything
they all flow oh that's just the flow
and there are
there are people who could do both
there's people who rap like that that
are [ __ ] fired you're like um
yeah am tech nine like there's some
dudes who could really get down but like
i think that just everybody has their
own thing like
you know and then there's guys like
royce who are like [ __ ] old
jedis like royce the five-nine can do
anything it's pennies elite
oh it's crazy do you like it like
intimidating when you know you're like
did you first of all do you know race is
getting on the record
like or is this something you said to
him i'm gonna be real with you bro i
ain't intimidated by nobody
i'm working a session with lil wayne lil
wayne montgomery but i mean
royce is a much better rapper than
little wind for the record it's
debatable
little wayne is bigger he's debatable i
don't know man race is a [ __ ]
murderer bro i got to be in the studio
with royce to really because i witnessed
this man wheezy like
different off the top record the verse
and say i don't like the middle erase
the middle and then go back in and just
no not go back in he's still there and
do it right there
after he set a race yeah so you you've
seen wayne's creative process what is
that like is it no pen is it no
pen no pen it's just he might listen to
the beat a few times
chuckle laugh a little bit and then walk
to the board did he just punch in as he
goes
no one shot deal really and if you don't
like alan or he don't like to go back
and fix it just say yeah let's do that
over do you how do you
do your thing because obviously you're
the one of writers one take
you know what i mean you don't write
down anything no no no no you do okay oh
yeah
myself to bust my brain to try to
remember that yeah i've noticed nowadays
like
uh a lot of rappers especially now with
the way like melody infused music has
like kind of taken over
like a lot of artists they'll just go
into the booth and then they'll like
they'll lay down like uh the melody like
and then they'll sit there and listen to
it and then they'll just punch in line
by line that's like
that's like what when somebody needs a
ghost writer
you i you you let me hear the beat and
you tell me like
you mumbled to it this is the type of
flow flow because now you need the word
you know
i've seen it it's it's actually it's a
reference it's like yo they'll lay that
down and then they'll sit there and
smoke and listen and then they'll go in
and just punch
in no but it's but that's but it's it's
it's still creative it's still creative
it's still true it's just not it's just
i feel like it's harder to be able to
say what you want to say and get your
point across
without thinking about it too much
because bobby rahman
multiple words meaning multiple
things at the same time with metaphors
punchlines and
it's just it's just you know i'm a fan
of that
um when we're talking about harlem who
do you have as your top five harlem mcs
ever
ever ever on big l mace
cam um
not me take yourself out all right um
damn i thought it was more than three
from hollywood i think dave east is
making his way into that car no davis is
a young legend that's my
god catalog though man he's still young
he's got a lot of catalog yeah davies is
my god davey's
yeah davis is definitely he's definitely
up there but
as far as my top five i would say
big o cam mace
do you guys out of respect you put asap
rocky in there just because of the wave
that he created
as far as maybe not lyrically he's not
not liberty
he ain't in there asap rocky is nice
though know he's
he's a different type of rapper he's a
little bit more creative
when it comes to like putting together
rhymes and songs and it's dope
still but it's not that type of rap the
big big pun
that type of rap that i was influenced
by
like oh caught it yeah but caught in
ain't really like he might not even know
who
they of course i do come on man oh okay
okay
uh bodega bans is fire he i don't need
that's probably not in that conversation
but he's my god
he does he definitely deserves my [ __ ]
you know what i mean deserve a shot
because he's nice he's definitely who
else is from harlem or not we're not
thinking of somebody bro
yeah but he just wasn't uh what was his
name child of the ghetto
oh that [ __ ] was so fire it was so good
i mean i think that one album crazy
yeah yeah yeah but he's like he did
catch a body
and find himself you know what's crazy i
was like in poughkeepsie before he
turned himself in
bro before he turned himself in i was in
poughkeepsie performing
and and then i'm on stage rapping and i
see
somebody get on stage with like a big
colorful
bubble coat and i'm like i ain't coming
nobody
i could see it from from the side of my
eye so i look
as g depth and he's just like going
crazy but he look a little like
oh so i'm like you know i talked to him
afterwards we we spoke um you was there
forever
yeah i'm just trying to remember it
clear but shout outs to him he was just
that was right before he turned himself
in so i knew it was something a little
bit a little bit off but shout outs to
him he's still at harlem legend
yeah mace i feel like doesn't also get
enough respect as an emcee
mace was crazy yeah that's face get all
the props in my books
no i just feel like in general we talk
about like base out overall you're
saying you had a crazy run man
crazy run double double up was a little
disappointing but
you know he was trying to get out that
contract that's how i looked at it he
was trying to get away from it there
were some sh there was like two records
on double up
but i remember buying double up and i
was like oh damn
because you was trying to match it up
with that hauling world album
harlow oh yeah that's right the harlem
world album they came out like that's
the triple player they came out super
that that's when he tried he tried to
he dropped double up to get out his
contract with puff that's what he's
trying to do
and he was like pretty much he said it
like he was kind of forced to
put that guy put together that album
whatever when you were a kid was like
when him and cam
and big al was that
like movement like known in in harlem
like
it was children of the corn right yeah
but that was like
i was too young for that yeah yeah i
mean once i got older i doubled back and
listened
but i was too young for that people
don't even realize that mace had like an
entire
you know murder mace was a real thing
yeah
yo it was so crazy when mace came back
as
like with the jesus [ __ ] and then he
went back to the gangster [ __ ] with g
unit for like one mixtape i was so
confused
i was like what but honestly i'm at the
same time i might have been confused
but i was i was hyped though i'm like
okay
murder back on murder time okay yeah
that didn't work out though
yeah and then he went back to the the
welcome back album
with the brewers hat on and then yeah i
actually got to meet mace very nice guys
you uh have you have you ever worked
with mace nah
no yeah you got to bring murder mace
back for a verse man
i would love to do it soon with mates
mace is a legend man of course man
[ __ ] one of the biggest do it from
holland oh for sure i
i would argue peak if we're measuring
peak
the biggest yeah i mean he's the only
artist i know that went triple
i'm talking ab i'm not talking about
total run or influence on the culture
but i'm talking about like commercial
success peak wise
for like a year maybe what about with
cam and mace
it's it's one of those two commercials
who you think had was bigger oh mace you
think so
oh yeah why do you think that bro
that's like that [ __ ] because he has
songs with mariah cause can't make it
right no i think it's i think it's like
heart like
bro that that like 12 month [ __ ]
run mace was like the guy well he
brought cam
in no for sure no you're right yeah
confessions of fire i remember like [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with that originally because mace
was on it mm-hmm
what was the song on that album where he
was talking about [ __ ] his aunt or
his mom or some crazy [ __ ] it was some
wild [ __ ] the song was actually called
confessions of fire nah you bugging he
ain't saying that though he ain't say
the mom
not the mom or the aunt though no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
no no you're talking about you're
talking about when i rape that poodle
and try to turn the poodle into all this
noodles on confetti the song confessions
of fire he said that's what he's
confessing
hey look up the lyrics to that to the
song that's what i'm telling you but he
ain't saying
there was some wild [ __ ] he said on
there about oh yeah yeah
he might have said he said no he said
see what that dust does
he said i might he was saying a bunch of
off-the-wall [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and i was
like this guy's crazy i don't know if it
was not i don't think he said the mom
would love
that but it was it was some [ __ ] that
was like off the wall like that though
where i was like oh this guy camera is
different i asked him i said yo
i see your flee why you um switch to
style said nah you know
[ __ ] be trying to take my [ __ ] man see
eminem rain with the whole [ __ ] i
let him have it but he was doing it
before
he was doing that dark [ __ ] on
confessions of like four hi kids
you want you like violence yeah because
i remember thinking like there was the
horse and carriage record and then i
bought the album and i was like oh no
this is some
there's some other this [ __ ] is dark
he's
yeah yeah look him up you know what was
dope too
uh uh uh to join with him at odb
that was classic oh yeah yo what's up
man boulette kev here shout out to the
homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love
man and let me tell you something we
don't take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design
no license but just crazy so make sure
you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the uh scarface they got
tapatio
they got wwe how about chef from
southpark you know what i'm saying
whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife
uh anyway um shout out to old dirty
bastard too
go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
what do you what do you think is cam's
best album his best overall album
i'm gonna go purple heads or
i'm a purple haze guy though purple haze
yeah [ __ ] that killer can beat that
he make his beats like the craziest be
i don't know if that was a sample
whatever it was whoever did the killer
come
i was like oh no that was that was oprah
steve shouts to my god prestige
the sample sounded like killer can but
he came in
and sung it over and they made it as a
sample like try to alter it so [ __ ] my
[ __ ] mom and father
but when my girl got sodomized i was
traumatized shove the dick down and
throw
okay okay i said man [ __ ]
test
i was trying to get he was in la uh
earlier this week and i my boy i was
trying to get him to come through
that's like a bucket list interview for
me who that killer of course
yes that's the killer shout out to the
whole set buddy
i have your phone sir
all good buddy cameo plugin cbd
yeah shout outs to my guys my guys ryan
henry and the good guys over at legends
legends of hemp you know i mean we got
some um some dope ideas coming man cbd
um cbds drop cbd energy shots
cbd lines what else
massage oils vape pens we got a whole
load
of stuff coming so so so the cbd
uh side of the game you guys got
unlocked
pretty much it's a worldwide market
listen you're not on the mic buddy so
yeah i tried to get him to brief me on
the way but i couldn't remember
everything but
yeah you know cbd is a worldwide market
that's what he said exactly you know
it's not restricted like a
marijuana type of thing so you can ship
worldwide and
you know it's healthy it's like you know
what's fair
are you a healthy guy of course hell
yeah i dropped 20 pounds but
since the last time i came here how did
you how what did you do to lose the
weight
i do keto and um bro i got on keto i
lost weight
and then i got off it and now i'm fat
again well i'll be off and on
and and i don't it works it works yo
like
you go months strictly on keto bro what
i did was i stopped
um i did the i started doing the keto
but i cancelled my gym membership
and i ordered the nordictrack treadmill
put it in my credit
bar and i just woke up screen on it and
[ __ ] yeah yeah and i just walk
walk up hill for 10-15 minutes before
every meal
and then work out at night you know what
i'm saying did you do everything from
the christmas studio in the crib
right yeah i did that i did that right
before coving
right before covey hit people are saying
that uh
there's like a big exodus out of new
york right now like people are moving
and [ __ ]
have have you noticed like people
leaving no i heard like manhattan's got
like 40 000 open apartments right now
not just a lot bro
really hell no bro well [ __ ] for
everyone's rent price purposes you kind
of you know that'd be nice right
yeah hell yeah i'll be like thinking
like yo
no everybody's not paying 5 000 a month
especially for these apartments like you
enter these apartments because these
apartments been there for years
even the hotels are [ __ ] up you'll be
like i just spent 600 dollars and the
hotel is the size of my closet
yeah no it's nothing like that in new
york are so small
there's nowhere to put your [ __ ] like
wait what what's the fact that
there's nothing like la hotels you ran
it like you'll get it on expedia and
then you'll get in and you'll be like
wait
it's the element you see it you got you
had some old pictures up
yeah no that [ __ ] crazy nah yeah because
i know with the kova [ __ ] like i heard
that uh just a lot of people are
a lot of people are leaving california
because it's so expensive l.a
because of l.a i'm not gonna lie no i
mean it's great
i could never live in new york i love
visiting new york but i'm a west coast
guy and just
why you feel that i just don't like like
everybody's just so
everybody's loud obnoxious everything
moving fast
it's just you go outside and it's stress
[ __ ] walking down the street
yeah yeah yeah they got their [ __ ]
game face on
mm-hmm it's like out here i could go
outside and not see nobody
no i'll hear that you'll walk past and
they'll say what's up to you yeah but
even like
it's impossible to avoid strangers in
new york if you're gonna have a life
in new york to go to work to go whatever
you have to out here
i can drive from point a to point b and
have zero interactions with people i
don't know
that's how jersey is new york is so like
you got to get on the train or even you
got to walk to get to the like it's just
a lot bro
and then the parking situation is
horrible you got to pay for a parking
space every month all kinds of crazy
yeah
yeah the only thing out here is that
traffic you know the track but but
perfect i was supposed to been here when
i moved here
the radio station's in burbank and
burbank's pretty expensive
but i purposely was like i'm gonna eat
[ __ ] and pay more money
so i never have to get on the freeway um
so i got my studios right here in
burbank north hollywood area the radio
stations in berlin oh this is birdbank
this is the burbank north hollywood like
border okay so if you go like
half a mile that way you're in burbank
okay radio station like five minutes
from here
so i was like you know what like i'm
gonna just pay more for my rent so i
don't have to deal with
what you said because that's what
everybody like the traffic gets you
[ __ ] stressed out thinking about that
[ __ ] out here yeah bro
the gps says seven minutes it took me 17
minutes bro
it was traffic for no reason then i had
to tell when it cleared up
i told the driver i say oh bro drive
what are you doing you know it's
definitely
i would probably rather still deal with
the traffic than have to like
deal with the people deal with the
trains oh to deal with the trains
yeah well there's no trains out here i
mean there is but i don't think people
really don't take them like that
oh it's not like that it's like a jersey
train jersey's not here in jersey
i fell asleep uh in new york i was on
the train
and i fell asleep yeah i woke up and
you woke up at kenazi i woke up in
spanish harlem
oh that wasn't that far but no i took it
from like downtown
and i woke up in spanish harlem it was
like three in the morning bro i get off
and i come up and i'm like
well you still good at three in the
morning in spanish harlem and you lucky
you ain't wake up at hunts point and
i was like okay damn this is so this is
spanish harlow so i'm like try to walk
around and find my entrance into the
subway to get to the other way and i'm
like
at the time i'm like real tight with
bodega bam so i remember hitting them
and i'd be like hey bro
i'm right here in my camera here
because i just woke up and got off the
train no spanish harlem is dope
it's cool i mean it's laid back yo
harlem is a vibe bro
i just think it's like like i felt like
if i
remember every like you know there's a
few times i talked about moving to new
york and i was like yo if i'm gonna move
to new york i'm either live in jersey or
harlem
because harlem is like still technically
it's it's still technically it's like
the first
borough outside of like like if you're
going towards like you're leaving
manhattan
it's part of manhattan it's part of
manchester but yes we've got manhattan
harlem washington heights that's old
manhattan
and washington heights is oh my bad
l-e-s manhattan
harlem washington heights and washington
heights is like a big big spanish area
right yeah dominican shout outs to all
my dominicanos up there
and then from there it's the bronx then
it's the bronx maybe a few blocks away
you could just cross a little bridge you
in the bronx
shout out to the bronx man shout out to
the ex
yeah what do you think why do you think
um for people who don't
who aren't from new york man every
single borough has its own flavor
it's it's very different like you could
go to brooklyn and it's like
you feel like you're in a whole nother
place even parts of brooklyn now
you like [ __ ] hipster [ __ ]
everywhere and then you
you know five minutes away it's a
dangerous place
yeah is that most in new york is like
most of new york becoming gentrified
or is it still like no it's just some
because brooklyn is
[ __ ] crazy yeah brooklyn is central
i mean this is no but there's a hipster
what part
and williamsburg oh okay i don't really
know brooklyn like that ain't gonna hold
you
yeah neither do i try to stay away from
brooklyn brooklyn serious
brooklyn seriously white girls with
[ __ ] armpit hair and [ __ ]
brooklyn was different when
uh my guys the wave gang
they they go by the wool now you know
what i mean but they had me
in brownsville projects okay i just
remember brownsville by the way shout
out to mlp
just reading about brownsville as a kid
in double xl yeah they had me in
brownsville
projects and when i got there like when
i went to when i
really seen the projects firsthand
that's when i seen like
this is totally different from harlem
this is nowhere
harlem ain't got nothing on this this is
different
this is like walking past the police
with a bottle of rose
and they don't say [ __ ] like this is
different like they all they care about
is shootouts and they might not even
they might not even walk up they they
gonna call for backup you know it's just
dark over there
it's different yeah it's like it's
different bro
yeah i just i just vividly remember
reading billy dan's in a little fame
talking about how they used to shoot
people off
like they used to just oh they from the
ville they're from brazil they used
shoot people off the top of their build
like like they were snipers or something
shout outs to mlp i met them too what do
you think is the craziest neighborhood
in all of new york
craziest neighborhood all in new york
and all of new york that you've been to
maybe
that i've been to damn
they gonna be mad at me i can't just say
one yeah now they you know
no brownsville is like the crate to me
in new york
nah new york could see if i say no now
it's like word so we ain't gangsta like
that
nah but um i think brownsville honestly
brownsville is different it was it would
be some people from east new york got to
tell you
brownsville for real brownsville
yeah man shout out to mlp yes sir first
family zone you know what i'm saying yes
sir
well look your ep is out uh yeah go get
that i really rap two
out now on platforms yeah i'm on the way
but i'm gonna drop another epc
that's the problem i've been having is
like i dropped the upstage
i got a nice response i laid i fell back
for two years yeah you can't fall back
no more bro
yeah not so i'm not today listen let me
tell you if i give you any advice in
today's world bro just keep dropping
non-stop and you're independent right
thanks so just
dude run up your independent catalog get
that nice [ __ ] monthly residual
income coming in
yeah and run that bro like take a page
out of
what like result is doing as far as like
the quantity of music they're dropping
and own all of it you know what would
what sparked me to do that
dirty i had a cold conversation with 38
special another example just like yo he
looked at me like
why are you holding on to the music for
sure now this is not
this is not the same era right it's not
the error to hold on to music but see
that i was always a customer don't
overthink your rollout don't overthink
any of that [ __ ]
i was old i was always accustomed to one
album a year that's how you do it drop
five albums a year yeah that's what i'm
gonna start doing i'm being serious
dropping next month again november 30th
perfect facts just keep going dawg and
like
then you know you'll be like yo damn
these monthly [ __ ]
what's your distro are you doing like
tune chord district right now
i'm putting this project out through
video shout outs to video but i got
tuned core i messed with different
like i got my brother all that distro
kid right right you know
yeah yeah they all work pretty much the
same yeah i own
my mat i just i just got my masters back
from warner brothers for one of my
albums
now i'm trying to get my first album
that was number two in the country
hopefully they gave it back to me catch
records okay he won
alan holla at me man and y'all owe me
some money too but i'm not gonna make a
big deal
let's work things out you know e1 is uh
what's the guy's name ellie ellie what's
going on alan grumbler helen grumlin
yeah shout out to steve lobel we'll try
to get
steve's real real close friends with him
i could try to make that happen for you
yeah let's do that
boom well listen man we got a freestyle
dropping tomorrow so
this is monday today's monday tomorrow
there'll be a it's going down
jail rider freestyle yes sir boom
perfect